Speaker 1: All right, let's get to the
mailbag. People loving the mailbag emails
pouring in about the mailbag. Info at David Pakman
dot com is the place to write to abuse it and lose
it. Hundred 120 viewers now auto filtered into the
trash because they are sending too many e-mails.
OK, let's get right into it. One of the best
parts of when we stream large live events like
a Trump rally or a debate or whatever. Is lots of
people looking for coverage of that event who have
never heard of our show stumble across the stream.
And this generally is a great thing. It's one of
the fastest ways that we grow our new audience.
The downside may be it's sort of like a funny,
you know, it's a mixed bag is people who are right
wing nuts who stumble across our coverage and then
get really mad when they realize that they are
watching a left wing stream. And I got a bunch of
those. I got a bunch of those. Thanks to the Trump
rally, air rode in. I can. You're an absolute
asshole. I continued listening to Trump's speech,
but I'm sickened by your idiotic commentary.
Learn a bit of history, you asshole. You're more
interested in giving a commentary on the audience
than anything of importance in the speech. That's
absolutely untrue, and I take issue with it. Can't
wait to see you give applause. During Joe's
next guard of garbled, unintelligible, lie
ridden diatribe to six people. I can't think of
any time I've applauded during a Joe Biden speech.
Finishing with your with y0u are y0u are.
It's almost legally required in hate mail
that the wrong your vs. your is used. You're a
total C word sent from my iPhone. OK, so this
is one of the greatest parts about covering Trump
rallies. People just looking for the rally stumble
across and are highly triggered, triggered,
triggered, triggered and people just looking
for the rally or stumble across us and go, Hey, I
like this guy. I mean, I subscribe to the channel.
Similarly, Mitchell wrote in In All Capital
Letters about our coverage of the Trump rally,
who said Mr. Pacman misspelled. Of course, as
a conservative American, I love my country.
I love our constitution and people like you are
a pathetic lib tardes. The way they love the
Constitution is weird, because much of what Trump
said during the rally was completely indicative of
not caring at all about the Constitution. Excuse
me, do society a favor? I'm choking over the words
Do society a favor and commit suicide. I think
they meant suicide. Get the f out of my country.
What a country we live in, folks. What a country.
I don't know that there is much more commentary to
make about Mitchell's email. And then lastly,
as many of you know, Alex Jones recently went
after us infowars conspiracy theorists
going after me for looking like a predator
and not taking live phone calls, which of course
we do. He attacked the bonus show as well.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And here's a message from Bobby,
who was really pleased with the Infowars
segment. Watch Infowars today. Hahaha.
It was very sweet watching you get completely
busted on Infowars. You are a total loser. Suck it
a whole B.S. artist. What I love, love, love
about that particular message. Is that Alex Jones
is so diminished in his audience because
he's been kicked off every real platform,
he's off YouTube, he's off Facebook. I can't
even I think he's off Spotify, I don't know.
He is he he has almost no platform left.
So at the end, I only got two emails and
one voicemail from people who saw the Alex
Jones segment and agreed with him. It's really
something how his platform has just evaporated
almost completely. All right, next is Kate.
Kate has A.. Let's get now to the substance. Kate
Rhoden Why do far right Republicans keep burning
things? Hey, David is a frequent listener. You
piqued my curiosity when you mentioned Car Hart's
vaccine mandate for employees and how that caused
right wing customers to burn their own clothing.
I couldn't help but see a parallel between this
and the Nike items being burned and destroyed
after Colin Kaepernick protested police
brutality and racial inequality in 2016,
while also remember when they threw their careers
out the window. Why do far right Republicans
keep burning things? What is this accomplish?
What's next? Books the well, but yes, books the
planet. They're already doing that. I truly don't
understand this might be worth inviting a guest
on your show with a background in psychology or
something of the like to discuss and investigate
further. Thank you for being such an honest,
engaging source of truth. Yeah, if anybody,
I don't know exactly who would have
expertize in this, but it would be very
interesting to speak to someone who can explain
psychologically this phenomenon of burning stuff
and the flame retardant Carhartt clothes
impervious to burn attempts from their very
people. It's I mean, you really can't write this
stuff, but a very if anybody can suggest such a
guest as Kate is mentioning, we would be glad
to reach out to them. Kristof writes in about
couldn't care less. David, sir, I watched your
segment today about the poorly capitalized.
Tucker Carlson Today show and his misogynistic
propensity for a patriarchal society. There was
audible cheering in my house when Carlson's guests
said I could care less about what people call him.
And you stopped the clip to correct the statement.
Absolutely. Using that phrase incorrectly drives
me insane because it makes zero sense to
the point of the individual supposedly not
caring. It is very common to hear it phrased
incorrectly, even by highly educated people.
Thank you for correcting it. Why do you think it's
so difficult for people to use, couldn't instead
of could for the phrase? I don't know. I mean,
guys, listen, it's. Think about it logically.
If you could care less. You're saying you
care. Imagine the phrase I could care less,
but I actually care more. So the correct phrase
is I couldn't care less. I care so little.
I couldn't possibly care any less because
I already care. Zero. Please, guys,
please go out there into your communities and
do what you can to make sure that the phrase
is used correctly. I appreciate Kristof noticing
my commitment. To that phrase. And quite frankly,
I could care less about how the phrase is used.
And by that, I mean, I care. I hope that that's
clear to everybody. Stephen wrote in with an
existential question and wrote, Our traditional
peanut butter cookies. Actually, candy traditional
peanut butter cookie recipes consist of peanut
butter, sugars, eggs and sometimes vanilla. Is it
candy? So I think the answer is no, and I'm going
to give you two reasons why. First of all, many
peanut butter cookies as their primary ingredients
have peanut butter and or flour. Now I know
that there are peanut butter cookie recipes that
contain no flour, and so you've got peanut butter,
and then often it's a very high amount of sugar.
I still think that they're not candy. I think
we could consider them junk food. But candy
typically has as the primary ingredient. Sugar
or chocolate like chocolate based candies would
have chocolate and then sugar. So I don't think
and this is a question of paramount importance.
I don't believe that peanut butter cookies
can be qualified as candy, but I am
open to having my mind changed on that. All
right. Here's a really important email I got
last week during the Tucker Carlson
patriarchy. Jason Whitlock segment I said
that I don't have any problem exploring
questions about men and women. That.
You know, preemptively shutting down areas
and saying, we can't talk about that. I have
a problem with, but we need to understand what it
is we're looking to do with that information and
whether we actually already have the information.
And claiming that we're just asking questions is a
way to troll because we already know the answers.
I got an email that from a female fan who said,
David, flirting with misogyny. David, listen,
I just watched your video called Tucker guesses
says patriarchy is good and I was a little
put off, by the way. You spoke about it. Sure,
you acknowledged that the idea of a natural
patriarchy is wrong, but then you said you're open
to investigating potential biological differences
like math aptitude. My goodness. Imagine you said
you're down to investigate whether Asians
are biologically better at math than whites.
It's been investigated. They're not. Or whatever.
Come on now I get that most of your audience are
likely dudes, but I think they can handle it. No
need to coddle their egos in this way. This is a
really sad email. It is now 2022 and it blows my
mind. Even educated humans like yourself are still
saying s like, this just sounds ignorant, sir.
I'd even say You're flirting with misogyny. I'm a
fanboy, I'm a fan. But boy, that was disappointing
to hear. I could not disagree with this more
strongly. I am against saying, here's a list of
questions you can't explore at all. You just can't
explore it. I mean, listen, guys, if it turned out
women were way better at cardiothoracic surgery,
for some reason, that didn't relate to economics
or geography or what. Right? Like if women
were just, we imagine we researched it and we
determined there is something inherent. Women
are better at cardiothoracic surgery. I would want
to go to a woman for cardiothoracic surgery now.
It might turn out that because of historical
oppression against men in that field, this is
this is we're making this up that there's really
no that there's there's an observable difference
which we can explain to discrimination. I would
also want to know that why would we say that
can't be looked at? So I think it's very dangerous
when folks take this approach that you can't even
ask these questions. The issue I have is that
these questions have been asked for a long time
and we have answers to just about all of them. And
as I pointed out, there is no evidence that women
are less capable for jobs other than circumstances
in which there may be a physical limitation. OK,
listen, you got to lift 200 pounds and many
men and most women can't lift 200 pounds,
so you're restricted to mostly men and a small
percentage of women who can lift 200 pounds. OK,
we've got an explanation, but I am very concerned
about these things where these things cannot even
be explored. Part two, by the way, is if
you explore things like this in a fair way.
The imperative is, what are you going to
do with the information? Is the information
going to be used to discriminate? Is the
information going to be used to insult
or even worse? That's also a factor. So I am not
one of these just asking questions, people and
every question I ask is being asked specifically
and in bad faith to justify discrimination. The
more of these questions that get asked, the more
we learn that discrimination is inappropriate
and it's wrong and it's unproductive. OK,
but the email saying you can't even ask that.
That that's not the left, I recognize
that's not the left I recognize at all.
OK, last email here from William offering
pardons to the writers isn't Trump also
signaling to future rioters that he will pardon
them, thus setting the stage for election related
riots in the future? Yes, to some degree. So
at the Conroe, Texas, rally when Trump said,
first of all, not only did he say,
we may pardon some of the rioters.
He also said we're going to have some of the
biggest protests ever, sort of again alluding
to more violent protests because that's what a
lot of his followers want to do. He absolutely
Speaker 5: is
Speaker 1: starting to plant a seed
about future potential repeats in different
contexts of what happened on January 6th, and
his devout followers know it. They recognize it,
and it's very, very dangerous. What we have to do
is prevent Trump from being in a position to be
able to convince people to do that. Send your
emails to info at David Pakman dot com. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Sign up at Join
Packman dot com and you will get instant access
Unidentified: to today's long.